pogchamps 3 is brought to you by gaiuki
as gayaki celebrates 25 years
of regenerative yerba mate they want to
thank you
for being a part of their mission
achievement to steward and restore over
200 000 acres of rainforest
come to life at gaia key dot com slash
chess
hey hey still better than excuse me bad
winner
bad winner ludwig is one killer
keep it going
[Music]
wait chess.com watching right now still
[Music]
hi sweetie how's it going um
i hope you cheer me on in my match i
love you
and as per usual cutie i didn't listen
to a word that led had to say how is he
sound
um how's he standing well typically
cocky overconfident and full of that's
usually how he's sounding but i don't
know how he's sounding today i haven't
listened either
oh they already started they jumped in
yeah but she could have used your advice
before this
situation happened because in the petrov
after e4
the knight hits the pawn taking it you
should not take back you need to kick
the knight first before you take this
pawn
because of this exact sequence if the
knight moves out of the way
then white will have a discovery so if
the knight goes to f6 this knight moves
it's check on the king and knight c6
kicks
and you can't block that would be a loss
there
uh-oh nico looks slightly confused
and mikko's yelling
oh gosh my god
feeling out of sorts
and
i don't know what to say
is mikko okay mikko miko's dealing with
this
on an existential level
and well love was thinking
ludwig almost looks frozen he's thinking
so hard right now
interesting moves is frozen you know
something is wrong
because usually a very talkative lad
and look at this ludwig played pawn to
d3 and that's a knight
so mikko brings the bishop out to defend
the square
but ludwig takes a night for the cost of
just a pawn
i don't think mikko is at the point
where she understands point values we
talked about it
and she kind of hit me with the blah
blah blah blah blah which i understand
um i feel like that's the first thing a
bot should know how to do is
quick accounting that isn't what we use
calculators and everything for
yeah he's a unique unique bot
got it and well ludwig's popping his
head so i think he feels pretty good
there's a check made in one threat on
the f7 pawn
you think mika will not see this no
no oh she
will probably bring out a knight or a
pawn i don't think she will see the
checkmate
and sometimes we forget that it's not
just the palm center text if you push
the pawn thinking it's under attack the
queen
still goes to that very square that's an
easy thing to make a mistake
about because you think the queen's
capturing the pawn but no it's trying to
go there with checkmate that's the
bigger thing i mean shoes oh yeah oh
and um it's game one
hey hey still better than excuse me bad
winner
bad winner ludwig is bad winner
okay how about this i will play slower
i'll play slower and
uh i'll try to use
i'll try to think i'm not going to show
you the shirt
cutie made me wear it i don't want to
wear it i've been asking him to change
his pants for the last three days
i can't make him do anything that's not
that's crazy it's that work from home
loungewear
he can just chill in the same sweatpants
for oh my gosh
oh gosh my freaking awesome girlfriend i
can't read all the fine print but that's
she's a bit crazy she has anger issues
but she's a perfect mixture of
sweetheart and warrior i love her so
much
she's my life flirt with me and you'll
be dead or something like that have you
put that to memory or did you just read
that very quickly
okay i made the shirt i wrote it oh okay
got it got it
i'm just kidding it's from amazon i just
read it really quickly
oh i couldn't even i could barely see it
i just saw the really large
print and that's about it
all right and they're off yeah they're
obviously loud puts a knight in c6 to
protect the pawn e5 so
now we'll see if kodmiko goes for bishop
c4 the italian game
and yes she does staring at the pawn on
f7 potentially for attack but i think
ludwig
his experience here he knows how to
handle this
miko said she was going to use her brain
this game is what
she learned from the last game she said
i'm going to use my brain this game
the weird thing to hear from a bot brain
bot
really don't go hand together so well
but i think it's working this new tactic
is working
and let's seems hyped he seems
really into this position but he hasn't
moved
what does this love face say to you
telling a story he's telling a story
at the end of the day chess.com's motive
is to get more attention to chess and
their website
which is done by getting big people on
but big people don't always have the
time but they're big for a reason it's
because they put time on another
thing please please don't be too hard on
contestants who aren't able to put as
much time as
like tofu in the chess it is not a flaw
or a mistake it is
just because they don't really know what
they're signing up for i think pogchamp
should be just fun and it's not our
fault that ludwig is so sweaty and he
tries so hard
okay does he yes he plays chess
every single night on an alt account he
has an alt chess
account not this ludwig ogren one
he literally has an alt check don't
spill his secrets
i'm going to because mikko just wants to
have fun
but why can't you have fun and try hard
at the same time
no absolutely not okay i'm just trying
to
you know stick out for lud skywalker
over here no
no no i just think you know some of us
some of us we just want to have fun we
just want to have a good time myth myth
is one of them
you know maybe i'm just defending being
bad whoa
whoa come on don't don't be so hard on
yourself you approved so much
during part two well
yeah well i didn't get invited back to
pog3
so it wasn't my decision
super rude of you me what did i do
you didn't ask me no we didn't have a
conversation about this they told me i
didn't have
500 000 subs on youtube so they wouldn't
invite me back
oh well i don't even have a youtube page
so then they told me they'd invite me to
commentary so i wouldn't call them
sexist again and i said okay
oh okay well now you're here never mind
your time won't call you sexist twitch
i mean chess i'll still call twitch
sexist
oh gosh and well ludwig looking more
serious
he's biting his nails i'm just going to
keep developing like this
idea
i understand that what happened he just
took my
bishop right then maybe i'll take
hmm took my bishop that's okay
it's okay it's fine she's not gonna take
one of those pawns maybe i can go
she should but she's trying to figure
out a way to get active here
i'll just take this there she goes
it's fine well done
it's very pensive she's really thinking
hard here she's really thinking about
her moves here i
this is she's down a minute on ludwig
and he's going fast he's having no mercy
as soon as she just curses out of
nowhere and well we saw what happened
with
charlie yesterday against mr beast when
charles started playing a little too
quickly
mr beast found great ideas to even trap
charles queen so you have to be careful
you don't get overconfident but tonight
right now
took on c5 and ludwig now sees that the
queen
can go gobble up that night yeah this is
overwhelming right now oh she didn't
move her
bishop her bishop is free
right does she create a threat but
lovely
true i miss that nobody can just take
well it happens right because you
think about the bishop was hanging a
second ago and now f4 is just like
maybe we'll tunnel on that bishop but
the queen needs to be taken care of
first and larry can just take this pawn
on f4 and continue with the attack
against the white king
so yeah it looks really good for ludwig
he obviously won the first game
he's the much higher rated player very
experienced and
i actually didn't see any games from
code miko in the last few days after her
match against charlie
so maybe she wasn't practicing or maybe
she was getting coaching
that i didn't see
yeah i'm not sure if she's doing any
off-stream coaching
well you could have lent a hand yeah i
should have as a friend i should have
pitched in a little more this could be
on you but she was
banned for a very long time oh so
well that's not good that's not going to
help yourself yeah yeah
i think she needs your coaching though
well we'll set up a time we'll get in
there
this is why chess and i hate to break it
to a lot of people watching this is why
chess does not equal iq
i know that miko is smarter than ludwig
1 000 million percent but then when
people are like
oh he's she's bad at chess so she's
stupid
oh gosh get off your high school she
moves to e1 she's a genius
yeah those takes are terrible snap
intakes are terrible
so it's mate let's thank you no it's got
the thinking music on
[Music]
all right fun little uh pin here
oh
[Music]
he's got this
a kitty is a checkman on the next move
if the king goes there if he brings his
knight in
wow this is such a sick checkmate oh wow
yeah i see that
what a dope mate yep okay
and we returned with the players lovely
congrats on the 2-0 score there
and first question is when's the last
time you change your sweatpants
okay can cutie cinderella
never be accepted to do commentary again
if she's gonna harass me
and talk on me i changed my sweats
i changed them oh okay finally oh
finally mine arse i worked out this
morning
and i was wearing a dirty shirt for a
workout
what am i supposed to wear a button down
now for workouts no
it was like three days old dirty covered
in hot sauce
yeah no it's a working man's shirt i'm a
working man i wear a working man's shirt
you play video games on a computer
not even i react to stuff it's different
okay and i and i broke a sweat so look
at this
so i'm it's hard to work stressed him
out
i was stressed out on the italian game
really
yeah you played a pretty tight italian
at the start and i didn't know what i
was doing
no way are you being sarcastic no being
dead ass and then you made like eight
blunders then i was fine but until then
i was pretty nervous
yeah amigo are you going to do any
lessons maybe with cutie cinderella
you need more lessons mikko i would love
to do more lessons with you can you
teach me how to beat ludwig well i can't
even beat ludwig
might take an army mikko all right can
we put both
take down one two combined
maybe if it's parts which in this case i
don't know
just frankly i mean chess.com does have
the four
player modes so maybe me miko and hess
against you ludwig
well maybe 2v2 me and has first youtube
boys versus girls
i am i for sure am i just think really i
love this boys versus girls idea
i would love to latch on that tess would
you rather be on our team or his team
everything's great i'm gonna teach you
something called the stonewall miko
what's that no that's what you should
say gotta get over the stone
we love the stonewall you've been
playing it for a year just do anything
else say
just try something it's always stonewall
this mission taught me this occasionally
you want to talk about you want to talk
about that anyway anything else you want
to add
well why am i getting throwback to me i
don't want to get involved in this
situation here
in fact cutie cinderella we are
co-commentators we're completely equal
here
anything you'd like to say to ludwig he
um as an adult man uh he still wets the
bed and i want you guys to know that
wait what all right see you guys later
oh i don't know how to leave the call i
don't want to leave the place
i figured it out i figured out i'm
leaving i'm leaving
bye